-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
During yesterday's annual
White House turkey pardoning,
President Biden joked that
the only red wave this season
would be if his dog knocked over
the cranberry sauce.
[ Laughter ]
Oof.
It's too bad his dog didn't have
the presence of mind
to knock over the microphone.
[ Laughter ]
A cranberry sauce red wave?
[ Laughing ]
It would be the slowest
wave ever, just...
[ Laughter ]
During yesterday's event,
President Biden said
it was important to remember
the true meaning
of Thanksgiving --
getting high
with your weird cousins
when things get
too tense inside.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden is reportedly
planning to use the month
between Thanksgiving and
Christmas to make a decision
about running in 2024.
Well, whatever you think of him,
it's impressive
that an 80-year-old man
is planning that far ahead.
[ Laughter ]
If I was 80,
I don't think I'd even
start bingeing a show
that had more than one season.
[ Laughter ]
Make sure it was a British show.
In a new interview,
Congressman-Elect
Maxwell Frost said
despite being 80 years old,
President Biden
can adequately represent Gen Z
because Biden also knows
what it's like
to live in a house
you'll never own.
[ Laughter ]
Dr. Anthony Fauci today gave
what is likely his last
coronavirus briefing
before retiring
at the end of the year.
And you can tell
he's kind of given up
because he gave the briefing
from a rave.
[ Laughter ]
According to the latest numbers,
home heating costs are expected
to increase this year
by nearly 30%.
And now that you're all
caught up with Dad,
Mom would like to say hi.
[ Laughter ]
In a new interview,
Harrison Ford said that
in the upcoming installment of
the "Indiana Jones" franchise,
he will be digitally altered
to appear younger.
'Cause it's not like that
earring was doing the trick.
[ Laughter ]
New York City
is auctioning off gifts
that were given
to former mayors,
including
a New York Yankees clock
given to former Mayor
Rudy Giuliani.
He doesn't need it anymore,
'cause it's always
five o'clock somewhere.
[ Laughter ]
A man in Missouri recently
pleaded guilty
to robbing a bank last year
by writing a demand note
on the back of his own
birth certificate
while wearing an ankle monitor
for a prior offense.
Wow, that case should only take
Merrick Garland about a year.
[ Laughter ]
Rapper Snoop Dogg recently
launched a pet accessory line
called Snoop Doggie Doggs,
which includes
plush toys, bowls, and leashes.
Even crazier,
he hadn't done that already.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
11% of Americans said
that they find the sound
of a baby's laugh relaxing,
while the other 89% said,
"Oh, damn it, the baby's awake."
[ Laughter ]
"Laugh it up,
you [bleep] monster!"
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, what, you don't have
work tomorrow?"
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
the gas station chain Sheetz
launched a promotion this week
to lower the price
of a gallon of gasoline
to just under $2.
Of course, you gotta buy
a hot dog, too.
[ Laughter ]
Math joke!
That was a monologue.
[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]